[Music]
all right i have
a pretty cool romantic
story for you guys this uh
is a story about of this is the story of
amanda and skylar
sorensen from utah and they're mormons
and they have a very unconventional
marriage and i think it's pretty cool
and pretty beautiful how they're trying
to how they're making it work
a lot of unconventional marriages come
out of utah huh
just like a guy with like 10 wives oh
true yeah
have you seen that documentary there's a
lot of those polygamous documentaries
which one you talking about i don't know
i just saw one
the one that we saw uh this guy was like
yeah you think it's cool to have like
three wives but each of them are mad at
you and you gotta
like you gotta try to get everyone for
it was great
is that one called the me and my ten
headaches i can't yeah no sounds about
right not but
i did all of them though they they seem
pretty how many have you seen yeah no
there's a lot of documentaries
yeah and it never seems like i think
guys they get into the situation
saying i'm gonna be
and you see the reality and the guy
looks like he hasn't slept
in [ __ ] well because the whole thing
is to expand the kingdom so they're
having
like the whole point of having multiple
wives is to have multiple kids like so
many kids as many kids as you can
and they have yeah so they have a lot of
kids and then they have a lot of wives
and then
they got to provide it and also cater to
all of them
dan bilzerian's hope is to have no kids
at all yeah while having as much sex as
humanly possible yep
no kids no wives all of it
fulfilling uh so yeah so for amanda and
skyler sorensen
uh their unconvent unconventional
marriage
is the fact that she's straight and he's
gay
and they're both 25 and they're making
her work interesting
yeah so what about when she want to suck
some dick
they're making it work they don't really
go into detail like that why
that's all anyone wants to know i do i
was kind of wondering that too
that's the most important thing maybe
she's asexual like maybe she doesn't so
they don't [ __ ]
it's just a marriage she's straight oh
she's heterosexual yeah but would it
be if one of them wanted sexually
be sexually gratified right because
that's kind of what you do in the
marriage right
like where you kind of like yeah but
like but like what
where do they get that fulfillment then
or do they both not need it
i need to know well yeah what if she
just doesn't care for sex
but i need to know they they say so i
quote
uh they do say that
because if they both don't need it that
kind of makes sense
they're like we're best [ __ ] friends
okay here we go is sex
or sex separate than the marriage
regarding the sex aspect
i had to skip down a little bit god just
skyler the guy in the in the
relationship
he said that sexual attraction came from
i mean trial and error okay sexual
attraction it came from trial and error
error and a lot of practice we have our
struggles of course like every marriage
but we
but me being gay hasn't been the biggest
issue in our marriage it's been
communication
normal marriage things so he kind of
skips around and doesn't really answer
that so they do do it yeah they do do it
but
for him it's like it there's more of a
mental olympics i think to get to that
they got married first and then he found
out he was gay and then
no they got together knowing he was gay
so whoa
so they're mormons and so in the mormon
religion uh you can't go to heaven
unless you're
in a uh a marriage of man and wife
man or woman that that so he's trying to
secure his heaven
to heaven yeah is he allowed to have sex
with
a man and still be married to the woman
uh
i don't know if that's something that
they're they're even into like that's
not even in their picture of
of like having sex with men but then
staying married together i don't think
that's even in their
on the what if he
okay what if he's openly gay but he's
not in gay relationships because it goes
against his religion but then he decides
to stay faithful to his religion by
being in a straight relationship which
yeah marriage union between man and
woman yeah so he gets
his uh heaven card so he secures that
and he's like well if i have to get
married anyway i guess i'll do it
with my best friend and she finds them
attractive or whatever the case
hers is right it sounds like a
complicated thing like that
that's what it sounds like yeah that
sounds pretty complicated but it doesn't
seem like he's interested in having sex
with
with men at least he's not you know
bringing attention to that
but he's like hey i'm gay but i don't
wanna yeah so he went viral uh
because of his twitter account someone
came across his twitter account and his
bio reads
gay and happily married to an amazing
woman and that got shared around twitter
and he went viral
pretty interesting that is really
interesting yeah and then another tweet
of his
uh which was also shared around and went
viral uh he wrote
being in a mixed orientation marriage is
like going to disneyland and having some
people tell you you'd be
you'd be better off at six flags six
flags may have more roller coasters but
it'll never beat the happiest place on
earth
so he was just respecting his wife and
saying hey my marriage is happy man
and back the [ __ ] up because a lot of
people going viral for this
you know you're gonna get a lot of
people with their opinions and whatnot
so how can you not have questions though
absolutely yeah what are your questions
what are our questions maybe the
happiest place on earth for him is
heaven so that's what he probably means
yeah
i mean if it depends on what you you
value more i guess if you're you know if
you
truly you're in this religion and that's
where your values are and you're like i
want to get in heaven and that's what
i'm living my life for
then that makes sense for them i'm all
about like letting people live their
lives and like yeah if that's
that you want that life like good for
you man like it makes you
everyone's about like he needs to cater
to my needs
if he's gonna be gay i want him to be
gay and happy that's right that's so
true yeah it's like on one of his uh
he can't be gay and straight and happy
you can't have all that if he
asked people for advice and then they
said i think you'd be happier in a gay
marriage
um then that's different but doesn't
sound like he asked him do you remember
his bio
it sounds like he's asking yeah he's
begging for all of our input
yeah yeah he wanted to go by totally
yeah so since going viral he's you know
tweeted
a couple of different things so for this
one he said what i've learned from going
viral
one there are a lot of good people but
also a lot of bitter ones who are only
willing to tolerate the decisions
regarding your sexuality if it fits
their
very small political box and then two
my wife is even more amazing than i
realized so i guess the wife has been
very supportive of him and through like
just trying to like
figure out like his identity and and and
also commitments
to religion and marriage are they gonna
try to have kids uh yes so
he's also said that um uh
i quote i've always pictured i've always
pictured this realization of family in
my life
marrying a woman having children raising
those children
and so uh they did have a child but the
child died 24 days after birth
he was born less than 25 weeks into the
pregnancy so this guy has a lot of
discipline
you know to like i am this sexual
orientation
but since i wanna go to heaven this is
my religion
i'm gonna do this and i'm gonna be
married to someone that i'm not
sexually attracted to and i'm gonna
commit to that for life
maybe his definition of marriage isn't
romantic and just sex and all that stuff
too like
maybe it's like well there's all these
other benefits this is a solid person
that i
trust and that'll probably be a good
mother and all this and then like
you know maybe those are the things that
he values higher than
romantic love there's so many married
dudes out there who are
gay who are in straight and women like
relationships yeah exactly
and then they have kids and like all
that kind of [ __ ] and but they repress
it and it sounds like he's
like nah i'm not doing that so he's open
about it but he's still gonna
carry on with this lifestyle yeah the
difference between him and
like slim some of those guys you're
talking about is uh most of the guys
stay in the closet for most of their
lives and maybe they come out
uh in old age you know or after the the
wife dies
in their old age they're like oh i can
finally be gay
openly whereas this guy is just like he
went in like hey i'm gay and i want to
be i want to be married to a woman
and that's i don't know that sounds
refreshing too at in this time in day
and time i don't know why
i really like it but it seems to have
stirred up a lot of
you know controversy in the lgbt
community and uh
and and a lot of the backlashes actually
come from the lgbt community
and so he said uh we made this decision
together
we just asked for the same grace and
understanding that other people in the
lgbt community are asking for because
we're two consenting adults exactly
yeah you just made a choice like just
support it it doesn't hurt anybody yeah
but some people are
very insecure about themselves sometimes
so everything has to line up with the
way that they live and like
if they're out and proud and they're gay
they they have everyone else needs to do
that too
and like it just it just throws a glitch
in their matrix when they
see wait you're gay and in a straight
relationship and you're
happy what the [ __ ] yeah yeah
and he probably is because he's a mormon
but hey little you know let him do his
thing
he right now is saying i make that made
this choice i'm happy with my decision
i'm a consenting adult
leave me alone so leave them alone yeah
who are you to say that oh
you're actually not really happy you're
holding it in or whatever it's like
[ __ ] let him be
you don't know if he's happy or not you
don't know yeah true and this
is skyler and amanda
that's amanda skyler and then
that's skyler she looks very happy there
looks happy super happy and amanda
i wonder if she took those photos
because she's holding the camera she she
actually does
she runs a video production how does she
take that picture if she's holding them
he probably took it
this one this photo's not as good as the
photo she's taking though so
i'm like she's the photographer for sure
yeah and then uh and then they they've
seen professionals too to help them deal
with like i guess their situation yeah
um
a couple called upon dr ty mansfield
he's a private practice
uh marriage and family therapist and he
said whatever path you choose there are
healthy ways and unhealthy ways to
navigate that path
um and then in the adding that the
sorensens can find
authentic sexual expression through
nurturing of the
personal and spiritual bonds so i think
a lot of the the sexual
uh expressions are stems from like
i guess their spirituality and stuff
like that too so it's very very uh deep
you should just get conversion therapy
jesus
but the idea the idea of marriage is
like not only
changing constantly with time but even
like right now
in different cultures they just it's
just different there's so many different
definitions
and it's like just [ __ ] do what you
want you know like who
cares life is so short to be dictating
other people's lives
like you live your life who the [ __ ]
cares man if it's if that person's not
hurting you or anybody like just let
them
know i just think like if anyone can
stay together
and it's happy and it's working and it's
healthy for them and it doesn't damage
the lives of the kids
that's successful because over what 50
ends up in divorce right
so like true the point if you can just
stay together
and make it work and you have kids that
you raised up to be
like decent human beings why is that so
[ __ ] hard to do because that's not
the norm
that's actually rare
it's [ __ ] weird it's um it's i mean
marriage is hard work
yeah yeah i don't know man that's just
like too complicated dude just [ __ ]
do what worked for you
true yeah in another tweet he said uh if
you're expecting or even rooting for my
marriage to fail
to affirm your worldview that's [ __ ]
up first of all rude second of all
you're going to be sorely disappointed
so he's
very adamant about keeping this together
and making it work i feel like whether
it's like
straight couples trying to um control
how gay people are or vice versa
it's all because they don't have control
and happiness in their own lives that
they need to
project that onto others exactly well
it's just the same as when someone finds
religion
like if you know like a lot of people uh
find christianity later in life
and and for them it's like oh my god i
wish i had known about this my whole
life
and then they come off as preachy
because they want everyone to feel the
same way they
they felt but they don't realize that
they're just like
enforcing their beliefs onto other
people instead of letting other people
find it
for themselves you know true i give this
guy
a year
[Music]
do